the holiday season is here
and of course i figured i would give you
guys some ideas for stuff you could buy
so i think you guys are gonna like this
um
let's check out some products we can buy
a nice little collection of infomercials
i hope you guys
really hope this helps out you could
thank me later when your loved ones were
like wow where did you get that
well you'll see
[Music]
let's check it out
[Music]
nowhere to run nowhere to ride now
wherever there's carpet
blast off with fun slides yeah
what the [ __ ] are fun slides
amazing carpet skates that glide slide
or
ride you decide race with them play
games with them or just cruise with them
dude that's so sick how
[ __ ] sick is that
that is [ __ ] sick hell yeah dude
right exactly get somebody [ __ ]
radical
fun slides bring the good times inside
dude how [ __ ]
sick is that and go go go more fun than
socks on a polished wood floor
fun slides let you slide on carpet but
wait there's more
constructed of friction-defying super
smooth plastic secured by hook and loop
straps
shock-free foam and elastic fun slides
so like in case you happen to have tubes
that have carpet on them and you want to
do cool tricks um
i guess you could crush it with these
hey out of the way soap shoes we got a
new competitor in town
you safely zoom across any size room
heel to toe
heel to toe just push off and away you
go
check the replay whoa and away you go so
did you guys see that [ __ ] replay
gripper grooves provide traction and you
control the action
face off with fun slides hockey dance
like a maniac
fun slide across the house and then fun
slide right back
no matter what your size anyone can fun
fun
fun slide brothers sisters moms or
misters oh that dad is so cool did you
see how cool that dad was
did you hear the music check this out
anyone can fun fun
fun slide brothers sisters moms are
mister fun slides into the room
hey kids mom and i are getting a divorce
yeah oh yeah mom and i are getting
separated
fun slide
do not put those on the dog the dog is
not gonna be happy about that
maybe not down the hall around tables
and chairs
fun slide fall down and crack your head
open go to the emergency room on thanks
on christmas
all morning but walk down the stairs fun
slides are totally kid-powered and safe
for any carpet
and they come with a national parenting
center seal of approval thank god from
2004 national parenting seal of approval
so strap them on and see where
they take you you can get your pair of
fun slides that fit virtually every shoe
size for 14.99
plus processing and handling plus you
can get a second pair to share for 10
more that's not bad that's not bad
with free shipping that means double the
ride so you and a friend can both
fun slide as a special bonus we'll
include our fun slides tips and tricks
dvd that
dude that's dvds for how to do tricks
you don't get that anywhere folks
also features bonus footage of pro and
semi-pro fun sliders getting ex
how the [ __ ] are their pro fun sliders
how are the pros
and how is somebody not
put the entire dvd
up online oh my god there's this is a
whole community of these people
hey slides [ __ ] these [ __ ] the base
just sneakers
against the bank now i've never been the
applied aiding experience
since when you push off you can't go
nearly as far
including adults it doesn't seem to be
the case as you can see i wear a size
six shoe and my
there was a fun slide
party center they thought that the fun
slide
was gonna be so huge
that they built an actual fun slide
party center folks
fun slides carpet and skate park and
party center
can somebody please find out when this
closed because it was probably
immediately i can't imagine this place
did well
all right let's continue with the
infomercials i'm not we can't just get
bogged down
on the slit on on the carpet skating
okay guys
stream a 10 value free with your paid
order
if you've got carpet you've got fun
and ask about the trick stick slide rail
sold separately
what there's a tricks trick stick slide
rail
i was so excited i could barely say it
you've got fun and ask about the trick
stick slide rail
sold separately hey this christmas party
is getting a little too quiet i think
it's time we liven it up with my
favorite christmas gift
mr microphone mr [ __ ]
microphone baby
what's that well you set the dial on
your fm radio and testing testing
[Applause]
these kids are having a fabulous time
with mr microphone
the cordless microphone that actually
puts your voice
on the radio there are no attaching
wires
so you're free to move around brought
by the way the simpsons making fun of
this was was one of the best things in
the world
you get a walgreens just pretty dope
pretty dope
all right uh let's see the perfect
christmas gift at walgreens woolworth
wilco osco venture weebles montgomery
ward
does the shoulder strap in your car cut
into your shoulder yes
oh my god that's a problem i could
relate to
that's a problem i can relate to
when you travel is your shoulder strap
too tight and annoying
yes introducing the titty bear
this isn't real right
this this isn't real
there's no way this is real
that's t-i-d-d-y bear the cute little
guy that eliminates
all those irritating shoulder strap
problems designed to make driving more
comfortable the titty bear snaps onto
your shoulder strap
and moves up and down to eliminate
uncomfortable pressure wherever you need
it
my shoulder strap used to pull so tight
i could hardly breathe
now with the titty bear i really enjoy
traveling again
with a patent-pending swivel design you
can easily adjust the tiddy bear to work
from either the driver's side
passenger seat or infant car seat and it
fits on all makes and models
just snap it on slide it to where it
relieves the pressure
and you're ready for a comfortable ride
the teddy bear stays where you
want it until you move it and it's easy
to slide out of the way when not in use
the cuddly teddy bear is filled with
soft cushy beads
so it snuggles comfortably to your needs
place it here
or here or anywhere you need to keep
those irritating straps from digging in
my shoulder strap was always digging in
but the teddy bear it makes it
comfortable for me to drive again
kids of all sizes love the cuddly teddy
bear and the secure snap-on button makes
the teddy bear safe and fun for infants
and small children too
the cuddly titty bear is so comfortable
and convenient to use
your whole family will love it
they just don't make things like they
used to anymore you know they just don't
out of your car all day like i am you're
really gonna enjoy the comfort of the
teddy bear
now you can have your own teddy bear and
eliminate those annoying shoulder strap
pains
call and order your titty bear right now
c flat says my [ __ ] alligator does the
same thing
neat
it it has to say and call now and get
and
i can't
call now and get a platypus absolutely
free
it comes with a cougar
order now and get an [ __ ] armadillo
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
oh penis blossom i like that
oh [ __ ]
for over 100 years we've been scrunching
and folding toilet paper what like
[ __ ] plebs imagine not using baby
wipes
imagine being poor and not using baby
wipes
finally there's a better way come oh my
god it's just a stick
oh my god it's a wiping stick
it's it's it's a wiping stick
for dwight the sanitary paper extension
arm and holder
the first improvement to toilet paper as
we know it since the 1880s
it extends your reach a full 18 inches
while it follows the contours of your
body and comfortably cleans
it's as easy to use as a shower brush
just pop on the toilet tissue and when
through
just press the release button and the
tissue drops right into the toilet
think about it toilet paper is really
archaic and disgusting
the comfort wipe is a modern solution
that's right
never touch another dirty toilet tissue
but what if [ __ ] gets on the stick
being a big eye certainly has its
advantages and its disadvantages
this is a great product it's
embarrassing to have someone help you
with your personal matters
the comfort wipe allows you to maintain
your dignity
while you maintain your personal hygiene
comfort wipe
the sanitary paper extension arm and
holder the first
improvement to toilet paper as we know
it since the 1880s
it extends your reach a full 18 inches
while it follows the contours of your
body and comfortably cleans
so if you or someone you love suffers
from the loss of range of motion
or if you're someone who just doesn't
want to touch dirty toilet paper
don't be embarrassed just get a comfort
wipe order now and we'll send you the
comfort wipe for just 19.99
plus we'll send you the get a grip just
pay separate shipping and handling it's
the assist handle that installs
in seconds getting in and out of the tub
has never been more comfortable
you get it all the comfort wipe and the
get a grip the entire 50
value for just 19.99 well that's just a
deal
i mean that's just a great deal you want
to stay covered after being wet but your
towel
just won't let robes are heavy and hot
and towels with fasteners
i think not now there's the wearable
towel
they're using the royalty-free breaking
news
music from like i think i think it's one
of the
apple movie maker i think
they're using the royalty-free music for
this fasteners i think
not now there's the wearable towel
the towel with arm openings the wearable
towel keeps you
totally covered and gives you the
freedom to use your hands
great for getting the paper ideal to
wear before
a swim and perfect to wear with family
and friends
it's ultra absorbent first class in
quality
and comes in red white and blue what's
totally amazing
is there are absolutely no fasteners
the wearable towel is unisex and can be
worn in a tunic style
and in a toca style
this is not sold in store so hurry while
supplies last
call right now you'll qualify for the
wholesale discount price of only 19.95
as an added bonus we'll give you this
backpack well have i not purchased one
of those
call one eight six six six one eight six
four four four
hi it's vince with shamwow you'll be
saying wow every time you use
this towel it's like a chamois i'm
scared i'm skipping shamwow
we all know hi billy mays here for
oxyclean the stains
we all know oxyclean we're skipping
oxiclean your favorite pants are him for
heels
but you want to wear flats how do you
fix that
women do you have is this something you
deal with
hi i'm lorie leland and you're going to
love this
it's style snaps from hemming my way the
world's first
snap and hem solution invented by a
woman
style snaps are the fast easy way to
change your hem to fit any shoe
top stylists magazines and tv shows are
raving about them
it's so genius just peel off the backing
of the style snaps
place them wherever you want your hem
and snap no sewing no ironing
and no gluing how easy is that now your
favorite jeans will work with every shoe
in your closet
stylesnap's unique adhesive makes them
adjustable reusable and safe on any
fabric
and because they're not permanent you
can change your hem as often as you
change your shoes
you can snap it up then unsnap it back
just like that snap it wide for seasonal
boots short for sassy flats or
sexy and tight for a look i'll be honest
with you
this is the one where i would say not a
bad invention
i i gotta say
this one is not a bad invent i'm being
honest it's not a bad invention
that's definitely right and it's not
just for him
came unruly lapels belts and pockets
without a stitch
perfectly hem a skirt or tighten a shirt
snap up tattered cuffs to give those
pants new life
or clothes revealing gaps and blazers
and style snaps is budget friendly for
growing kids
now they can even share clothes forget
praising trips to the tailor or
permanent tapes and glues
now you can change your hem like you
change your shoes during this special tv
introduction
you get 16 style snaps for just 19.99
order right now and we'll double the
offer absolutely free
that's 32 style snaps enough to snap and
helm a closet full of clothes for the
same low price
you get all this an incredible 40 value
for just 19.99
call or log on now hard to store
hard to handle heavy hoses oh i know
everyone knows this one
what a mess can you first off
that doesn't happen with hoses if you're
not an absolute
[ __ ] [ __ ] what were you doing with
your hose were you wrangling cattle
like why would that happen to your hose
what were you doing
huh angled and kinked
what a mess introducing the pocket hose
the hose so small it fits in your pocket
just turn on the water
in case you need a hose on the go watch
this mini hose grow
and grow and grow to maximum length to
this long
full-size hose no need for bulky ugly
hose reels
turn off the water and it goes right
back to its many size
hang it right on the water spout store
it with your garden tools
or just keep it in your pocket the
pocket hose is so light
it weighs less than this bottle of water
even junior can help
the pocket hose fits in the palm of your
hand and grows to a giant hose
powerful enough for really tough jobs
and when you turn off the water it goes
right back to its tiny size
ready to store even in a drawer and when
you need it pocket hose quickly grows
again
all right we got it leo with ease
traditional garden hoses seem to always
kink
but the pocket hose couldn't kink if you
wanted it to
the secret is the accordion design that
automatically expands when the water's
turned on
it grows like magic right back to full
size
and it's strong enough to pull this 5
000 pound suv
watch again just turn on the water and
watch it grow
and grow you said you had one of those
and it lasted one summer
bro the pocket hose is super light and
easy to handle
and when you're done even if you're old
stupid [ __ ] look at this old stupid
[ __ ]
using a pocket hose if this old stupid
[ __ ] could use one so could you
oh i'm just an old stupid [ __ ] and
being an old stupid [ __ ] that lives at
boca raton i love the pocket hoes
it practically puts itself away it
couldn't be easier
the 25 foot pocket hose is just 12.99
during this special tv offer call now
and you can get a second pocket hose
call now to get the amazing growing
pocket hose for 12.99
also be sure to ask about our special
deals on the 50
75 and 100 foot sizes call now and find
out about free shipping
you can crack them this way what oh my
god i have the same problem with eggs
all the time because i crack eggs like a
[ __ ] caveman apparently
you can crack them that way and we've
all done this
no i've none of this has this happened
any of you guys with eggs
i've never had this issue with an egg no
matter how you crack them you always
end up picking out eggshells that's not
true
that's not true you're lying this
infomercial's lying to us
anymore introducing easy cracker the
ingenious new product that lets you
crack open eggs
separate eggs oh my god we [ __ ]
deserve everything that we
if we're at the point now where we need
a device to help us crack eggs what is
wrong with people
even crack hard boiled egg quickly and
easily without the mess
watch it's so easy simply insert an egg
into the cradle
and squeeze to instantly crack and
release the egg from its shell
no more messy countertops no more slimy
stove tops
the easy cracker separates any size egg
from its shell in one simple motion
so you can crack them neatly right in
the pan no fuss
no mess uh oh crunchy eggshells ruin
those muffins
you would pull the even if it did happen
you'd pull the shells out right
with the easy cracker the shell is
always left behind
so you never have to worry about drop
shells peeling hard-boiled eggs can take
forever
but with one simple squeeze peeling
hard-boiled eggs has never been easier
separating eggs are a hassle but the
easy cracker has a special egg separator
attachment too
just place egg in the cradle and squeeze
to divide the yolk from the white
instantly
make fresh meringues for pies or low-fat
egg white omelets with ease
so don't ruin another egg dish again
just
crack crack crack away with easy cracker
now you can order the amazing easy
cracker with egg separator for only two
easy payments of just ten dollars
but wait call now and we'll also send
you easy scrambler
this unique automatic scrambler mixes
the yolk right in the watch
so it actually comes out of this what
scrambled ingenious
yours free so it's like a vibrator
cracker with egg separator and the easy
scrambler all for only two easy payments
of just ten dollars so order now
i'm sorry but you can't crack an egg and
use a fork to scrape
i don't unders why would
we deserve night
everyone gets callouses they're ugly
itchy and gross
and getting rid of them can be a real
pain
whoa ow ow
who did the sound balancing on that what
the [ __ ] man
my [ __ ] ears the [ __ ]
jesus christ
holy god until now
introducing the all-new ped egg power it
gently buffs away cal
oh so gross oh that's gross oh that's
disgusting
ew ew no
glasses dry your dead skin and gets rid
of rough patches
in seconds just look at these amazing
results
then switch to the smoothing roller and
smooth your skin to perfection
your feet will look younger feel baby
soft and always be ready for a night on
the town
the secret's the gentle nano abrasion
roller that spins at 2 000 rpms to
quickly and gently buff out the driest
skin
for smooth sexy feet the power ped egg
gives
instant noticeable results for years i
hid my feet because
my heels were dry and cracked and now
they are so smooth and soft i love it
men love it too
it's great for smoothing rough feet and
for dry calloused hands
before the ped egg power my hands were
rough dry and cracked
now that i'm using it my hands are soft
and smooth blade free pet egg power
is safe and completely painless it's
guaranteed
have any women use one of these these
pedec things
do they work
eggpower just 14.99 this offer is not
available in stores order now
dinner can take hours to making who has
the time
hi kathy mitchell here with my new dump
dinner cook
okay come on
dump dinner cookbooks
book now just dump and bake for full
meals in minutes
so delicious look at these smothered
pork chops easy cheesy tacos
roasted chicken with potatoes or this
the best pan pizza ever
cut up some biscuits i'm sorry
roasted chicken with potatoes or this
the best pan pizza
that's the best pan pizza ever
that looks like vomit
that looks like a plate of puke
ever cut up some biscuits in a skillet
dump on tomato sauce your favorite
toppings and cover with cheese
then bake for a delicious pizza stuffed
with all the goodies
yum here's my favorite comfort food
dinner not with chicken and mixed
veggies
add a can of creamy chicken soup a few
chunks of velveeta cheese
and topped with a can of crescent rolls
just look at this
a cheesy chicken pot pie with perfect
flaky crust
how about a new twist on meatloaf i
dumped ground beef stuffing mix
an onion soup pack and water into this
bag then just mashed it all together
now just cut off the corner and squeeze
into muffin cups after baking top with
mashed potatoes a perfect portion in
each muffin you'll love it
get great shortcuts too like this beefy
pasta no need to pre-brown meat or boil
pasta
dump it all in the pot dinner is served
in 15 minutes
i'll try this shortcut ravioli lasagna
dump frozen raviolis on tomato sauce
add fresh spinach and cheese layer as
high as you like
for steamy melty home-style lasagna
after work i
never want to spend time making dinner
now i just dump everything in and bake
to make the
ultimate chili mac and cheese stop
slaving over dinner
make delicious meals in a flash with
dump dinners just 10
but wait call now and you can get my
best-selling dump cake cookbook
just dump and bake for this scrumptious
razzin peach how lazy
are you just follow a recipe [ __ ]
who's this lazy
dump cake or use canned biscuits to make
fresh warm sticky buns just like grandma
used to make
you can get dump dinners and dump cakes
for ten dollars
with over 250 delicious homemade recipes
here's how to order
your eyes on these homemade dishes and
chocolatey desserts all made with ramen
noodles
really ramen noodles yes ramen
hi kathy mitchell here with my new ramen
joy cookbook
filled with unbelievable recipes
everyone will love
this entire basket cost under 10 and
wait do you see what you can make with
it check these out
ramen shrimp ramen tacos even ramen
sliders
watch this why brown some beef or any
other meat with a ramen seasoning pack
dump in a package of ramen a good sized
squirt of ketchup and a can of cola
i call it white trash soup yes cola
for a fantastic barbecue beef pasta
better than what they serve at the rib
joint at a fraction of the cost
want more form cooked ramen and egg into
a fast pizza crust
then add your favorite toppings for a
mouth-watering pizza
in minutes it's right here on page 84.
and here's my favorite
just dump some ramen on top of some
leftover chips okay i'll be right back i
got a pizza
add a can of soup stir and bake a
delicious feast for the whole family
all for less than three dollars what the
best and fast
and look i'm back what did we learn
she'll slide off with ease
add this insert and now what did we
learn toss in your favorite ingredients
to make mile high western omelettes
bacon cheddar and chives
even use egg whites easy to make and
taste great
you can even make is this for a
microwave i'm sorry i know it was gone
and i missed it
is this for a microwave
scrambled eggs for breakfast burritos
are over easy without
ever touching a fry pan crack two eggs
into the split tray
and you've got perfectly poached eggs
for or it's its own machine it's a
microwave
eggs benedict and more the secret a
unique thermal sensor that guarantees
excellent results every time now enjoy
fresh egg salad sandwiches
scrumptious deviled eggs for a
protein-packed snack plus its compact
design
stores away with ease egg chef also
makes the best steamed vegetables
just look at that if it's a steamer
color
and wait till you taste these zucchini
noodles in a stir-fry the possibilities
are
endless stop stressing and guessing with
your eggs
order my new red copper egg chef for
only 19.99
plus get my eggs and more recipe book
free if
red copper ever fails we'll replace it
guaranteed
call now and receive the omelette insert
and the poached egg tray
both free and here's something to get
excited about
i got it excellent excited i get all the
eggplant
please i i understand all the egg puns
trust me i get it
your own kitchen for just panties
disgusting plus it virtually cleans
itself with this cleaning cup and just
water ready for the next smoothie look
the blade is clean
now everyone gets exactly what they want
like she's still doing egg puns
she forgot that this wasn't an egg thing
so she's still doing egg puns
and cream for my grandkids it's that
easy
now everybody's happy the unique
emulsifying disc blade designs reverse
action technology creates a turbo funnel
that sends everything into the vortex
creating a perfect so like a blender
she's referring to a blender right guys
i mean that's what it is
big smoothie every time every smoothie
maker what do you mean execute do you
think a little bit of water is going to
clean the blade
my recipe guide including this recipe
for orange genius
a little milk and ice one orange and a
spoonful of the secret powder that's
probably already in your kitchen
just what secret powder is already in
your kitchen
so wait the selling thing is you if you
honestly think that i'm going to buy
this turbo action blender
so i could figure out the secret powder
because i am it worked i need one of
these i need to know what the secret
powder is
the secret powder is sugar slag at the
fair
stop with the lots of bucks frozen
coffee orders now you can make the most
delicious cold coffee combos for pennies
and with a sip lid it's ready to go
and that's money in your pocket for
safety this blade will absolutely
not turn on until the cup is locked
into position watch super strawberries
slush
veggie feel great with eight frozen
fruit frappe
tropical delight even melon madness
not only are they scrumptious but you're
getting 100 of the vitamins
and dietary fiber including the pulp
not just a glass of juice a smoothie
that no one can resist
especially now i'm going to make an egg
smoothie
that's delicious call the number on your
screen now to order kathy mitchell's
smoothie maker in white or red with the
large cup drip tray
medium cup cleaning cup ziplit plus four
free large cups recipe guide for only
three payments of 19.95
tired of food getting stuck to your pan
yes sir
or you could just use like pam or oil or
grease or yes
butter it does pay for itself thank you
gamsy marker it does pay for itself
sick of scraping and scrubbing and when
your meal won't fit you just want to
quit
who [ __ ] makes bacon like that
she made all the inventions frozen she
made all she's like a female billy mays
well i've got the solution hi kathy
mitchell a real rhonda popeel
my new red proper square dance pan this
is not your grandmother's old griddle
no scratches equals no stick ah nothing
like cooking up
nothing like griddle no scratches
nothing like cooking up screws like
grandma used to make
well there's no sticking everything
dances right off the square design means
you can fit more bacon or more burgers
perfectly and the high sides prevent
grease from spilling out
non-stick and no scratches try this so
she invented a square pan that's her big
invention a pan that is square
dump in tater tots then add cheese any
breakfast meat and cover with eggs
top it with biscuits and pop it in the
oven yes it's oven safe up to 500
degrees
and look everything you want for
breakfast and no extra
that looks disgusting i don't i don't
want that
i don't want your stupid dump recipes
you dumb [ __ ]
pans to clean even make 16 sliders at
once
you can't do that in a round pan
infusion no instead you can make 15
sliders oh god i lost one i can't make
one extra slider
pure copper and thanks to anti-scratch
technology it resists the toughest
punishment
swirl cheesecake into brownie mix with a
metal fork and create this delicious
dessert
even a bacon crust hawaiian pizza slides
right out
all right well look now we know her
problem we figured it out
we figured out her problem she likes
hawaiian pizza
she likes hawaiian pizza so we figured
out the issue here
she's just a terrible human being
she's a terrible human being hawaiian
pizza
this is one of her dump recipes she
could dump in this one
love pancakes here's a trick drop a
little water in the pan when it dances
you know it's hot and ready to cook
wow really what a cool trick
like these ooey gooey chocolate chip
pancakes no sticking
ever square dance works on any stovetop
even induction
got leftovers use tortillas add meat
beans and cheese fold like this
topped with lettuce tomatoes sour cream
and salsa salsa
try my square dance pad and you'll be
dancing all day plus it's dishwasher
safe
has food sticking to your pan gotten
completely out of hand tired of scraping
scraps
i've got the solution hi kathy mitchell
here with my new
red copper cookware so it's the same pan
but this one's a circle
what happened to the old square pan you
were telling me five minutes ago
kathy
the revolutionary pan made with
non-stick ceramic and soup
cooking cooking screws again [ __ ]
cooking screws again
this [ __ ] is cooking screws again for
strong copper
guarantees to stay scratch free forever
no scratches no
sticking it's lightweight yet super
strong so it won't scratch peel or chip
into your food
look biscuits dipped in cinnamon sugar
and covered with a sticky caramel glaze
then bake red copper is a baking that
looks like a stomach ache in a pan
pan with a handle goes into the oven up
to 500 degrees
and everything slides right out yum cook
my healthy crispy chicken fingers with
little or no fat or oil
red copper uses 100 pure copper so
durable you can chop steak and onion for
a melty philly cheesesteak absolutely no
sticking or whisk eggs without a mixing
bowl truly a time saver
red copper is pfoa and ptfe free
so it's safe for you and your family you
can flambe desserts broil flaky fish or
baked chicken parmesan
everything so it's a pan so it's just a
normal pan
slides right out even caramelized sugar
without it sticking pour over nuts for
an easy breezy peanut brittle
always a clean pen whisk it biscuit
sunny-side up it even upside down it
truly the most versatile pad you've ever
used
plus it's dishwasher safe are you tired
of fussing with giant pasta pots oh that
happens to me all the time because
because me because the thing is with me
i'm an idiot so i grab
everything that i need in one trip
including loose pasta
and throw it on a table i mean that's
how i make pasta i'm sure that's the way
you guys make pasta too
drainers timers stirring and testing
just for all play-doh pasta
did she touch it with her hand
what a dump well i've got the solution
for you
hi kathy mitchell here with pasta boat
the amazing new five in one pasta cooker
that serves perfect pasta without the
hassle
just put in the pasta add water to the
serving line and pop it in the microwave
ah yes a microwave a pasta just like my
grandma used to make
oh i love him it's a microwave a pasta
some fresh the microwave a pasta
it's that easy when finished place on
the strainer lid drain out the water and
you're ready to serve
look the stove uses boiling water to
cook the pasta but if the heat's too
high it boils over
too low and it clumps together pasta
boat uses the microwave to instantly
heat and keep the water
at the perfect cooking temperature it
actually does a better job
pony shells anytime dex cutie
i toss some cigarette butts in there too
yeah why not you might as well
you get it all two pasta boats two
strainer lids two steamer racks two
recipe books and the food chopper
a whopping fifty dollar value for just
ten dollars wow
don't delay imagine saying that a
[ __ ] microwave safe
plastic thing is a fifty dollar value
order today
just ima imagine saying that
i think the microwave was a mistake
i really do whoa look at that
i'm late if royce reveal himself to be
liquid snake yeah
see look that's a good one no one's done
that one yet a lot of wet bandage a lot
of timbal ones that's a liquid snake
that's very good all right it was very
very good
whoa look at that
yeah i've heard of your booty dubs i
know a lot of people watch it i've never
really watched it
we'll play this one though it seems it's
short
mom do you love me no no no hey
wanna try some of my big fat dumps [ __ ]
measuring cups
i dumped out all of these desserts in a
minute first you take a dump then you
bake it then you plop it on a scoop of
ice cream
peaches come in the bag now but you
didn't know that but i'm gonna take a
big
old dump on top then we could pour a
little generic canada dry [ __ ] on there
now it may not look that appetizing but
you just gotta dress it up a hot dump
coming through
oh back for more honey yeah i bet you
want to try some of this dark
dump i'ma show you how to make it oh
[ __ ] it's already done i'm gonna
sprinkle some kisses some marshmallows
in there and a little bucket of oreos
i burnt the marshmallows a little bit
but don't tell nobody about that
all right now over here i squeezed out
about five bottles of maple syrup and i
put some peanut shells on top then i
dumped three soft hockey pucks in there
flipped it upside down
yep it smells like maple syrup you ever
take a dump in a mug just drop in a
pineapple sprinkle that don't
flip that [ __ ] upside down put the cream
on top let it melt
i used to shake and bake all the time
but it feels better just to take a dump
you know
think of all the dumps you could be
taking if it wasn't for those kids
step your dump game up today for just
ten dollars i'm talking five store
desserts but
wait i'm gonna throw in dumps for
dinners that's right if you could dump a
cake that you could dump a deep dish
pizza no problem
i like mines with a lot of cheese now
that's deep i wore an extra tight bra so
my titties don't plop into the pan again
all right let's grab a box of pasta
okay it's pretty funny we're making
babies tonight first thing i do when i
get home is i take a big
dump and it's really sticky and gooey
burn my
dumps today i know you got ten dollars
not bad not bad
very funny